autre rassemblement celui organisé par
l'association uniforme en danger place
de la république à paris une
manifestation pour soutenir la cause des
policiers gendarmes militaires pompiers
et agents pénitenciers pour dénoncer
aussi le malaise dans cette profession
va écouter la vice présidente de
l'association 47 ans cultive depuis le
début de l'année on a fini l'année
même avec sa garantie un suicide la
nôtre énorme et ici pour les agressions
et tous s'y disent chaque jour c'est
important donc on est là on veut que la
france silencieuse bouge soient nombreux
dans la rue et on espère qu aujourd'hui
on va faire entendre
on attend du gouvernement pas qu'ils
soient humaines surtout ça et qu'ils
nous entendent la détresse des policiers
de tous les uniformes et qu'ils fassent
quelque chose parce que leur sur jean
[Musique]